been a long road brian las vegas heads
into the first heat wave of the year now
the risk of heat exhaustion or even
stroke remains high and can happen to
anybody
kate houston tells us who is most at
risk and how the pandemic could actually
have lowered
your heat tolerance we really feel the
effects we've been drinking a lot more
water
i would say the splash pad at centennial
hills park was the perfect spot for
families to cool off
david hawkinson came prepared my
daughter is in like the the sunscreen
long sleeve
shirt and loose fitting clothing
water water water parents like eileen
eadie say it's better to be proactive
because heat illnesses can happen
at any time the heat exhaustion sneaks
up on you you know you think you're
you think you're just a little warm or
you think oh i'm nauseous but
you know it must be something i ate and
and those things are all the warning
signs as temperatures heat up it's
important to remember basic levels of
protection such as wearing a hat
putting on sunscreen and drinking lots
of water
we're most definitely planning on a long
summer paramedic samuel sheller says
young kids and the elderly are
especially prone to heat exhaustion and
stroke
some exhaustion symptoms include heavy
sweating dizziness and nausea heat
stroke symptoms can include
hot skin with no sweating rapid pulse
and confusion
the heat does not discriminate against
anybody so
if you're out there in the heat for long
amounts times you will feel the effects
due to the pandemic forcing people to
stay inside sheller says it's important
for everyone to recondition themselves
to the high temperatures
taking your time out in the heat going
easy you know maybe the first couple
weeks of the summer
heat wave don't spend too much time
outside and really just kind of ease
into it this summer
kate houston 8 news now